well one of the latest to fall victim to
the fentanyl crisis here in las vegas a
four-year-old boy and investigators are
blaming his mother this is a story that
you're seeing here first on 8 news now
the i-team's vanessa murphy was in court
to learn the details and also has more
from the regional justice center
downtown
police say amber mitchell is responsible
for her own child's death after she left
her children alone in a hotel room with
fentanyl pills mitchell is in custody
but she refused
to show up in court it is
i guess nothing short of a tragedy the
34 year old woman faces felony charges
for child abuse and drug dealing
metro police say their initial
investigation reveals mitchell went
gambling and left her two children alone
in an orleans hotel room with fentanyl
pills on the bathroom counter her
four-year-old son ingested a pill and
died her six-year-old son nearly died
the clark county coroner identifying the
deceased child as securi cayetano police
say mitchell admitted she was going to
sell the drugs las vegas justice court
judge alana graham set bail at 200
thousand dollars after reviewing the
case including the allegation mitchell
took no medical action after learning
her son ingested the pill
detectives say mitchell told them she
became concerned her child had taken a
pill around one in the morning after he
appeared to act drunk she put him back
to bed and went back downstairs to play
poker detectives also say she said she
felt guilty and doesn't deserve children
and told them that she's just a mother
not a doctor and i didn't know oxy could
kill him i didn't know about fentanyl
according to the dea the synthetic
opioid is 50 to 100 times stronger than
morphine the da's office reports
mitchell has ties to california and
appears to be transient while a defense
attorney says she appears to have a las
vegas address she also asked the judge
for house arrest pointing out mitchell
receives public assistance and can't
afford bail judge graham pointing out
she was staying in a hotel and gambling
traveling to our community with the
fentanyl drugs not securing them
leaving her children unattended
for a significant period of time
by which they had access to and did
ingest and one of them unfortunately is
now
now deceased i do find that she's a
danger it was revealed in court that
mitchell's surviving child is in the
custody of child protective services
vanessa murphy live local now